pratiquer le foot au féminin ou pas la
question ne se pose sûrement pas pour
les millions de filles et femmes qui
s'adonnent à cette discipline à travers
le monde pas de questions superflues non
plus pour sabine de legros qui conjugue
de sa vie avec le football au point
d'être aujourd'hui outre une joueuse
accomplie l'une des responsables taux de
qui se développe ce sport dans notre île
spécialiste du 400 m à l'époque sabine
pratiquer le sport depuis toujours même
si la faute ballot ce qu'elle est
devenue à chausser les crampons
tardivement
moi j'ai commencé j'avais 20 ans oui
donc ça fait quand même vu l'âge que
j'ai actuellement ça fait quand même pas
mal d'années que je joue au foot hein
mais je ne sais qu'il y avait toute une
évolution qui fait au niveau du football
parce qu'à l'époque quand j'ai commencé
eh bien on prenait le ballon pour lâcher
devant en cours et après omar que lui
suffisait pas là
et maintenant c'est différent on pose le
jeu on essaie de trouver des ouvertures
il ya des techniques et mise en place
des amorties des frappes commençaient si
c'est super à regarder ça parce qu'il ya
plein d évolution qui fait dans ce sens
que dans l'esprit aussi des parents
c'est évoluer parce qu'un bon gros 10
beau le foot c'était laid mais que des
garçons qui étaient pour ce sport là à
envoyons peut-être quelques fait jouer
en regardant télévision ça permis
d'avoir une mentalité peut être des
parents donnent la possibilité à ses
fidèles au foot en venant jouer au foot
ils ont vu que vraiment ben c'est pas
vraiment difficile de jouer au football
c'est vrai si mr d'applications comme
dans tout le sport il faut s'entraîner
il faut appliquer les techniques et avec
l'entraînement tout progrès sont
justement à l'époque quand vous êtes
décidés pour sun foot comment ils ont
réagi vos parents des écoutes et moi ça
tombe bien j'étais la dernière fille de
deux des six dont mes parents à vingt
dix points peut-être plus comme je
faisais peu évolué et le fait que aussi
qu'il m'avait permet de faire la lessive
tout à fait début donc j'avais déjà
cette ouverture de pratiquer un sport
donc quand j'ai dit bon j'aimerais faire
au foot et non pas vu aucun inconvénient
et sachant que mon petit père comme nous
ils ont dit à la réunion c'était aussi
un footballeur il avait donc joué pas
mal dans pas mal et qui donc il avait eu
quelques réunions et pourquoi avoir
arrêté l'athlétisme pour le foot à ça
c'est une très bonne question pourquoi
la lectrice il faut s'entraîner presque
tous les jours d'accord et à côté ça je
ma vie a continué donc je me suis marié
ayant des familles j'avais des
responsabilités donc j'avais moins de
temps à l'escroc stade et bien je me
suis dit bon ben je vais donc plus ma
des révérends sport collectif je ferai
des copines promet des dents dans ses
démarches d'un vote retrait si beaucoup
de concret parce que c'est vrai que
c'était mon premier passion mais
aujourd'hui j'en suis fier parce que mes
enfants font la même chose que moi aller
simple est ce que vos enfants pratiquent
aussi le football quand il était jeune
deux petits garçons ils ont commencé
mais après sou
reeves et plusieurs d'autres sports je
les essaie de faire maintenant bon
personne de particules au foot ma fille
qui a 11 ans est un moment elle voulait
aussi faire le foot je lui ai dit bénin
parce que tu as d'autres possibilités et
à d'autres passions elle fait comme je
le dis c'est vrai c'est mon premier
amour la notice que maintenant mes trois
enfants il faut donc aux quelque part je
suis gâté dans ce sens et ce grâce
qu'ils viennent au stade quand même
pouvoir oui ma fille il est toujours
avec moi mes garçons ont bien moins
souvent parce qu'ils ont leur propre
chose à se préoccuper ailleurs je vais
dire mais il vient de temps son tome
voir dans des grands matches et sont
souvent la qualité plus petit monsieur
les menace au plus grand don qui me
suivent de moins en moins la violence et
le football sont malheureusement
quelquefois alliés qu'est ce qu'ils ont
pensé jeudi c'est dommage parce que à
travers cette violence on cache une
belle image du football et quelques fois
à cause de cela justement les femmes ou
les filles marion ville justement
d'aller sur ce stade
à l'opposé de sa dose en montagne
par ce passionné j'aime bien le foot ce
jeudi que georges était plus ou moins
attiré 1 à leurs côtés donc une quelque
part le foot me permet aussi de
m'épanouir et pièces et les changes de
collectif que j'ai fait avec mon groupe
avec les fixe autour de moi et vu l'âge
que j'ai je suis je me sens un peu
responsable d'elle à peu leurs mamans
leurs grandes soeurs d'entre eux aussi
une confidence qui fait dans ce sens là
et puis bon bain au sein de mon groupe
on a toute une entente qui est
formidable donc ça donne envie de
pratiquer vous n'êtes pas que joueuse
non je suis joueuse avant tout et je
suis aussi responsable un peu de mots
oui et à côté ça je suis aussi la
responsable du football féminin de
délier de la réunion quoi
vous êtes présidente de la commission
féminine de football oui la fonction que
pour l'instant aller que je que j'occupe
et d'autres avec la commission une fille
on envisage de mettre en place des
actions pour les jeunes justement de
façon qu'il n'y a pas une rupture entre
ses petites filles qui jouent à mixité
et après l'âge d'adulte avec des seniors
comme nous avons et que nous n'avons pas
la catégorie cadette donc il faut que
nous trouvons au système de façon que
ses filles ne dérive pas n'abandonne pas
le fond ne pas pas dans d'autres
disciplines est ce que vous trouvez
quelque chose de ceux qui s'inscrivent
maintenant ça fait quelques années au
niveau de nos effectifs on est stable
donc c'est bon aussi pour nous c'est
quelque chose de très positif parce
qu'il faut savoir jeudi à l'époque on a
commencé le football y avait 2 4 club
elle n'est pas autant maintenant on se
trouvant des avoirs donc onze clubs on
déduire 12 que ce qui dit toute une
année plus ou mois on tourne 24 23 est
ce qu'on peut espérer que mes joueuses
locales puissent aller évoluer ailleurs
justement on peut espérer par le biais
que cette fille intègre la sélection et
par la sélection faire voir cette jeune
fille à travers dont nos échanges dans
les pays différents à travers je pense
que justement si on aura un grand marché
si on peut éviter donc les responsables
du football féminin de la fédération
française parce qu'on puisse voir ce jeu
ne fait qu'ils ont des qualités ça ne
s'est jamais fait euh non ça s'est
jamais fait ce plan de cas mais il faut
savoir que nous avons défis qui ont la
capacité et la carapace d'être des
filles qui peuvent pas partie de la
sélection française
mais vous avez été aussi je vais
ailleurs c'est vrai mais c'est à dire je
ailleurs c'est au niveau de la sélection
nous avons pensé il ya quelques années
de mettre en place une section pour la
motivation supplémentaire pour
l'évolution la progression du football
féminin ça nous permet d'avoir un
échange avec d'autres pays justement on
s'est engagé notre président nous ont
engagé la coupe d'afrique nous avons
donc eu des rencontres à hors du
territoire de la réunion nous avons été
en egypte nous avons d'abord reçu
l'egypte ne l'a pas battue nous sommes
nous sommes déplacés un match nul
suffisait ce qu'on a fait un don s'est
qualifié pour les huitièmes finale de la
coupe d'afrique qui s'est fait en
afrique du sud
quand il ya un match féminin celui gens
se déplacent autant que pour les hommes
oui il ya des matches où il ya des mash
fort ou des gens connaissent que là il
ya des qualités et à l'enjeu est alors
un bon spectacle ils viennent par
exemple comme mon club et faux quand il
joue et on jouait vraiment où tout était
au vert eh bien il ya plein boom qui
s'arrêtent qui fais le toi qui sont là
autour du stade ont tombé amoureux de la
région très motivant pour vous ou fait
pas cantonnée dans le match on fait
attention au public un spectateur ça
nous intéresse pas c'est le résultat qui
est les bêtises qu'on va faire part pour
notre entraîneur shiva ne se créé après
il faut savoir que notre première c'est
un homme tout ça c'est si rare d'avoir
des phares mais je ne sais pas c'est un
club à je crois qu'ils ont des femmes
qui les entraîne chez moi c'est un homme
et avec la complicité de sa femme
heureusement parce que s'il n'y a pas
vraiment un potard ya une confiance
absolue et soutiens des deux côtés on ne
peut pas continuer comme ça nous on dit
merci moi je dis merci à tous ceux qui
qui peuplent football féminin qui
encadrent défi lacombe après je m'en
sers la
société il faut une organisation en tant
que femme quinze cantons pratiquent le
sport je parle que le fougeux par le
sport en général en tant que femme il
faut micro organisation parce qu'on a
dit familial on a ça dans le sport qu'on
aime donc il faut pour faire respecter
le sport qu'on aime il faut deux côtés
des destins entre la famille passer
sinon ça va plus marcher à 6 ans à un
détenu un petit peu pour les femmes
parce qu'il faudrait tempérament
particulier pour sa du foot oui il faut
avoir un peu de caractère parce que
c'est un être humain je pense que c'est
un sport qui va pas correspondre il faut
en vouloir il faut vous n'êtes rien il
faut foncer parce que j'ose asus si vous
n'avez pas que pratiquer le football que
tu reçois un coup ballon en face ça fait
mal hein donc c'est pour ça qu'à voir ne
doit pas nous parlerait un douillet tu
pas douillet peut-être pas marrant ça
vous ne sais quoi si je commence à
parler de la les tice d'abord rejeté des
mal aimés et donc j'ai fait les jeux des
îles j'ai fait deux celle de la réunion
le premier à 119 2,85 à l'île maurice
dont j'ai eu des médailles d'or les
médailles d'argent les athlètes
accomplis oui donc gg a passé les gars
moi mais au niveau du football bon il
faut savoir qu'au niveau du club ff où
on entend souvent parler dans les médias
les journaux s'il faut c'est une équipe
phare 1 et il faut reconnaître donc à
côté avec cette équipe on a quand même
eu de la coupe où on allait championnat
est une femme comblée oui je veux dire
on est comblé parce que je fais tout ce
que qui m'intéresse et j'aime bien ça
j'ai beaucoup d'amour entre deux mois et
vous travaillez s'est par ailleurs oui
je suis un petit peu collaboratrice mon
mari qui est de sa propre société va
vérifier
si rien de neuf pour moi grâce à lui oui
ça me permet justement de pouvoir
pratiquer du sport ward justement être
la responsable du football féminin ça me
permet d'avoir du temps parce que si
j'avais pas marre est aussi
compréhensible qui me donnait du temps
libre je pense que j'aurais pas pu
joindre tous ses doigts il est aussi
responsable du bureau donc ils viennent
me voir quand le temps le permet à
nouveau de temps en temps entre man 2 -
1 an de moins en moins maintenant parce
que il est tellement préoccupé par son
travail le dimanche est passé de nous
voir et quand on sort on va louer bennoo
sa compagne parce que d'autres loisirs
oui alors oui c'est vrai que l'âge se
fait sentir je sais très bien que ne
peut pas jouer au foot toute sa vie
s'est passé c'est un sport assez dur à
cebu talent beaucoup de villes dynamisme
et quand on vit on a pu tous aillent
donc je me dirige vers une passion qui
est là dans ce cas quand et surtout la
danse africaine que pensez vous des gens
qui croient que le football n'est pas
assez pour les femmes
s'apercevant que j'attends ces questions
là moi je voudrais sont des gens qui
n'ont peut-être pas vraiment vu un match
important il faut en revenir lors
qu'elle est grand match ce sur les
stades et voire peut-être saint-usuge
d'échanger les idées peut-être ça peut
donner une autre ouverture une autre
dimension du football féminin
vous estimez que le football féminin a
de l'avenir oui oui c'est pour ça qu'on
se bat au niveau la commission féminine
pour intégrer pour la reconnaissance du
football féminin de façon que dans
l'état d'esprit des garçons somme que le
foot bada est pour lui il faut laisser
ces dames et demoiselles à pratiquer le
football qu'est ce que vous avez envie
de dire aux femmes et aux filles qui ont
envie de pratiquer ce sport alors moi je
voudrais dire à tous ces jeunes filles
femmes oui qui ont la passion l'amour du
football devenir d'aller que une fois se
rendre à l'entraînement essayez notre
mans vraiment comme ça si c'est
l'ovation des qu'elle fasse qu'elles se
fassent plaisir
rime le feu et vu une faute au féminin